uh I said Denzel we got the Mariachi
band coming for he said Oh mariachis all
right okay all right mariachis so you
got all right what we got here okay we
got all the shown shot we got a set
right here okay hey you're very flowery
and very high pitch and very outgoing
unbuttons and fantastical and beautiful
and just dependents Larry this is not
about me it's about the American people
plain and simple but it's your party so
aren't you gonna be the candidate that's
just propaganda now we're gonna have all
kinds of candidates I'll just be one
we're gonna have regular American folks
running for president we're gonna have
all kinds midgets crack [ __ ]
everything you can think of check your
trades smell my feet give me something
good to eat
if you don't oh no I don't care I'll
pull down your underwear yeah Jim blue
and these guys get all these great
impressions you know so I said well I'm
gonna learn some impression so are you
guys all ready this is my nearest and
president he's got a lot of his ears ass
it's Sullivan I keeps are really gonna
do it's all of him like why would you
there's a bunch of naked people walking
around if your wife hasn't been laid of
course she's gonna go and see it has a
very similar voice you know it's one of
her they were here in New York stoned I
want to show you some real estate while
we're out there
own it own it own it own it own it and
own it and that when I sold to a
Japanese conglomerate and they took a
bath on it that was a very good deal
did you see the interview that Shaq did
right after they won the championship
the dude that was interviewing him was
more excited than he was so shocked
how'd he feel I feel good just want to
pick my mother took my father never got
at the unit make a shirt and I drifted
away and everything I did was going
effective the better you know
disappointment look isn't everything
like they don't say I'm just trying to
be I said what why did it take so long
that's my question I should have been
had me a task you see me
hi trikha trains
[Applause]
that's a damn good question trek trade
quite the conundrum
having said that my young costumed
friends as fate would have it I too have
a question which one of your little kids
can guess what I've buried under my
house
I can't he would just get into it
oh yes thank you yes tell the guys to be
home going what the hell going on there
yes there's a kid going that's not the
way yes there's like Martha Graham
Martha Madden ball and chain and kicking
bum yeah yes thank you
Kevin how are you nice to see oh shut up
Dave I worked on something just for this
moment
okay I had to write it down
[Laughter]
[Music]
Meredith
truiy thank you but I get a cappuccino
he said I went over there he made me
prank some more pop friends
that's why my always be cooler because
she maybe them Frank mercy we do go to
war I can assure you it will not be
another Vietnam because we have learned
well the simple lesson of Vietnam stay
out of Vietnam take my wife please take
her I I love my wife but she don't know
how to cook her cooking is so bad it is
terrible
yeah hey what are you looking at but it
why don't you make like a tree and get
out of here you know that then is a
great line if everything is so great the
stuff you guys are doing with the 50's
and everything no I had jackets like
this can you believe Emily I'm the old
guy listen here's the thing Steve King
what I got
listen Steve the fact is I listen I do
every movie Steve I'm everywhere listen
it's me Dwayne Johnson and Meryl
Streep's what I got that's all you get I
mean it's just that now now the way I
understand that dr. Cain said that Miss
Marple said that the knife that was
found in the back of surrett tional
what's the same knife that was used in
the kitchen by the maid Winnie Annie
that originally belong to the gardener
Ben Harper uses great putty off the
silver window somebody's lying
what are you on Morgan well I've been
thinking about this for quite a while
not really sure what I want let's see a
Big Mac quarter pounder with cheese
believe it or not that's what I do let's
see let's just go
[Music]